[Music]  if I could make 50 more movies with  these actors in this movie I would like  I feel like I have my theater company  and we could just keep working together  forever the greatest thing about making  this movie was the fact that you're  you're really building to the Wonder  Woman that we all love but not until the  end of the movie are you really like  that's now Wonder Woman so I think the  most exciting thing about Wonder Woman  is like literally seeing her loose in  the world now living those classic  stories of life here's a crisis in the  world here's Wonder Woman and what can  she do so I think it's it's not about  different I think it should be a totally  different movie but grand and now  full-blown Wonder Woman in the world  [Music]